así fue como el líder opositor ruso
alexéi navalni llegó al hospital de
berlín en el que ya recibe tratamiento
médico
y despegó en un avión medicalizado desde
homs donde estaba hospitalizado desde el
jueves luego de desmayarse en el avión
que lo trasladaba desde tomsk a moscú de
acuerdo con sus seguidores el opositor
fue envenenado probablemente con un té
que tomo en el aeropuerto de tomsk por
lo que la aeronave en la que viajaba
aterrizó de emergencia en omsk su salida
de rusia se produjo en medio de una
amplia polémica en principio los médicos
aseguraban que no era recomendable
trasladarlo porque el despegue y el
aterrizaje podían causar consecuencias
sin embargo el viaje fue autorizado tras
la presión ejercida por sus seguidores y
su esposa que se dirigió oficialmente al
presidente putin
aquel que tiene la exclusión
el diagnóstico de envenenamiento fue
definitivamente descartado con base en
análisis químico toxicológicos
el equipo médico ruso consideró que el
paciente puede ser transportado ellos
señalaron que el transporte es posible y
garantizaron que lo llevaran a un
destino específico que es berlín
esto nos lo enseña
según los médicos rusos el estado del
opositor se debe a un trastorno
metabólico versión que fue rechazada por
su doctora personal tanto francia como
alemania habían expresado su
preocupación por el estado de salud de
nava al cni y se habían ofrecido a
tratarlo el opositor ya había sufrido un
envenenamiento el año pasado cuando
cumplía un arresto administrativo